feminism is one of the biggest scams  they're indoctrinating young girls I was  even indoctrinated to think that your  career is going to bring you happiness  then you hit 40s 50s not married no  children and it's heartbreaking you're  not happy and I'm so happy and so  grateful that I figured this out in my  early 20s you have some women in their  30s 40s listening to cardi B dedicating  their lives to their career and they're  going to be miserable they're creating a  certain lifestyle for themselves that no  man is ever going to want them but then  we start hating on men because men  prefer younger women well that's not  really men's fault is it it's society's  fault Society should have told Girls  when they were much younger than at that  age they're gonna be most desirable but  no they were busy building their careers  and building all these different things  which Unfortunately they wake up one day  and realize just isn't satisfying enough  and so I think it's very sad